Kvantové počítače řeší jen ty problémy, které klasické počítače
nedokážou zvládnout —
třeba hledání správných materiálů pro zachycování
uhlíku, abychom opravdu
zabojovali proti změně klimatu, nebo vývoj
účinnějších hnojiv, která
nebudou poškozovat půdu a zároveň udrží
potravinový řetězec, který potřebujeme k nakrmení světa.
Jsou tu taky základní otázky o tom, jak je náš vesmír
poskládán dohromady a jak se hmota chová na atomové
a subatomové úrovni — to potřebujeme vědět.
Je to další hranice.
Pojďme se podívat na jednu oblast, kde výzkum už probíhá —
hledání nových baterií.
Baterie změnily naše životy tím, že nám umožnily nosit
počítače a chytré telefony.
Ale je toho víc, co se dá udělat — baterie jsou klíčové
pro naši čistou energetickou budoucnost,
ať už jde o pohon elektromobilů nebo
rozvoj obnovitelné energie.
Potřebujeme zásadně odlišnou chemii,
abychom vytvořili baterie
zítřka. Kvantové počítání
by nám umožnilo efektivně nahlédnout dovnitř baterie
během jejích velmi složitých reakcí a pomohlo nám
přemýšlet o nových materiálech
a struktuře baterií, které budou potřeba
k napájení příští generace zařízení.
Jak se tam dostaneme? Tím, že postavíme světově nejpokročilejší kvantová
zařízení a vývojovou platformu
a zpřístupníme je celému světu.
Jedině tím, že teď budeme spolupracovat,
dokážeme vyřešit problémy, kterým budeme
společně čelit v budoucnosti.